Good morning. I'm Lieutenant
David Valenta with the Las
Vegas Metropolitan Police
Department, homicide sex crimes
bureau. Here to brief you on a
homicide investigation that is
currently ongoing. First, I
wanna advise everyone with the
winning commute to be cautious
because we do have 215 The
eastbound travel lanes from Las
Vegas Boulevard down to
approximately Warm Springs are
currently closed down during
the investigation. We're
working diligently to get those
reopened and they should be
open in less than an hour from
now. Uh as far as the incident
we're investigating. Uh we have
a homicide where preliminary
information. It looks like we
had a road rage incident, some
sort of altercation occurring
up on the 215 while traveling
eastbound Uh. two cars would be
side by side. Uh unknown
arguments started at which time
one of the vehicles fired
rounds into our victim vehicle.
The victim driver was struck
causing him to crash his
vehicle into the center
divider. Uh before to arrest
farther down the road on 215.
Uh there was a second female in
the vehicle that was also
struck by gunfire. Uh they have
been the deceased is
approximately a 25-year-old
black male and the female is
approximately 25-year-old black
female. She's been transported
to UMC. Uh believe to be in
critical but stable condition
right now suffering from
gunshot wounds. Uh suspects are
not in custody right now.
They're outstanding and we are
definitely looking for any
public assistance, anyone at
approximately 220 in the
morning is when this call came
in. So, anyone would have been
traveling anywhere eastbound on
the 215, possibly even coming
off of the I-15 onto the 215.
We do not know where this would
initially started before it
turned into gunfire but anyone
seeing two vehicles that might
have been slowing down. Look
like some sort of road rage
incident or seeing shots fired,
seeing the accident. Uh
ultimately on 215 eastbound
there, pass the airport
connector. Uh absolutely
request your assistance.
Calling in to LVMPD. Uh you can
call Crime Stoppers to stay
anonymous. You can even Email
homicide at homicide@LVMPD.com.
Uh so, with that, there are any
questions. Any description for
a vehicle? Uh right now, very
vague description. Uh we have a
newer model. We believe four
door, possibly gray sedan,
possibly occup up to four
times. That would be the
suspect. That would be the
suspect vehicle. anything else?
Nope, that's it. Thank you very
much. It is the driver who is
deceased then. The driver, the
victim vehicle is deceased on
scene, yes. What part of the
215 eastbound did that vehicle
come to arrest? Uh several
hundred yards east of the
airport connector and the Warm
Springs flyover. So, it
could've happened as stated
several hundred yards even a
mile west of that and who knows
where the actual altercation
started before going to that
length. So, literally, anyone
that saw anything involving a
couple of vehicles, chasing
each other, driving side by
side, cutting each other off,
anything like that, definitely
give Metro Do you have an
update on where the closure
starts and how much longer it
will stay in place? It start it
starts at Las Vegas Boulevard
traveling eastbound on two
fifteen to Warm Springs. Uh
they're getting closed. Should.
be opening up 30, 45 minutes
from now. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thanks a lot.